やっぱりジェネリックが一番美味しいん
そうないこんにちははじめ社長ですこういうわけでック落としてもやります
肇社長の畑のオーディション第3回目開催でございます
俺と一緒に
働かないか入ってレギュラーの詳しい内容はですね茶畑のほうでも同が出せるんです
けどもまぁここは動く所に思と言いますがどういう気持ちでオーディションを開催し
てるの艦艇のちょっと説明しきっていきたいとおもいます
8募集要項が色々あるんですけどまずは男性ということ
そして20歳から25歳顔出しができる形で作業決まったら半年以内にこちら
一緒に動画作りできるよって方そしてで肇社長の畑のチャンネルメンバーとして専業で
出来る方
デートへと既婚の方とかの未婚の場合で子供がいらっしゃる方も今回のオーディション
は募集対象外とさせていただきますちょっとなかなか高流動的で何が起きるか分から
ない処分で雑記いって責任は持てませんが入っな作っ
いい人がいたら嬉しいなということで今回は本州しております始め者ちょっと畑であの
もうすぐ作って約3年経つわけなんですけれども
はじめちゃんの畑なんですけどもまあまあ台中に向けてキックをその穴が大きいという
かそもそもねなんかねはじめ者さんの畑よねー
勘違いされてる方が多い気がして俺全然の同じメンバーでずっとやってい
いますとか固定メンバーですがそういうつもり全くなくて1本目の動画でもいたと思う
んですけど持って変化し続けるチャンネルを作りたいなと思っておりましてなんかこう
ね10日イオンやとフィッシュちゃんとか決まった人たちでやってチャンネルもう
まったくもう亀が強いんで根元人がもう入れ替わり移り変わり祝えばいいなっていく
ようなイメージなんで
けれどもとりあえず変化をもたらしたいっていうのは大事になりますまあその考えも
ずっとこれでいいかがカギがないんですけどいつ現場は俺はそんな
こいつらで一生やっていきますって言うつもりももっとないし中に入ってやっていき
たいと思ってくれるんだから俺はずっと一緒にやってみたいと思うし
風て別に目標が出たら俺全然辞めていってもらってもいいと思ってるねそれくらい実は
の
ゆるい金真珠力はないわいろんな人がいろんな鳥を持って俺も参加しで一つのペン型と
か作っている実を作りたいと思ってるんでぜひと
が強い方だがそう俺が一番気にしてるのはでそのはじめ者とか酒ってついて肇社長あり
きだみたいな雰囲気がどうしてもあるんですけどこんな僕は作ったに過ぎないんで一番
僕が求めているのはその
自主性というか僕はもちろん楽しみますってますけどそんな僕よりも最もた竹よくし
たいとか自分で言うのもおこがましいと思ってるんですけども発射とたして働いている
イルカ youtube 楽しそうだなと思っている方が入ったら是非応募して
もらえると嬉しく思っておりますまあいろいろつべこう言ったんですけども3つだけ俺
がどうしても求めているものがありますひとつ
やる気これがないと始まらないですあの肇社長に乗っかってラックして人気になり体と
そういう考えた絶対言っても少ないですなぜな曲のオーディションでわかるんで割っ何
か狙ってんだみたいのに何となく感じてるんで
なんかそういう甘えた技持ちなのはちょっと俺は嫌だなっていう
俺が僕が肇社長弾みを変えてやるもっと杉江チャンネル知ってるだろう
いう熱い気持ちがあればもう最高でございますきもつのででもう一つがですねあのー
youtube の経験があった人がいいなと思っております
いきなりちょっとわかったにレベルが始めた東ハト議長もて3年がやってきてるんです
けども
も食いが良い中でやっぱりそんなめちゃくちゃノウハウがあるわけでもなんてこれが
決められた時間の中でを仕入れることをそんな大
たくさん
ちゃいましたけどお客さんを性ましたけどこっつきっきりでみんなに教えるわけでも
ないからそこらへんなでも撮影得企画とか編集等の知識がある人がいるとまたちょっと
変わるのかなって思います
動画の経験がある方はちょっと今回俺の中では大事な気がしますね即戦力ですね
そして3つめ協調性ですこれが難しいのは協調性だけあってもた
雨なんですよコンピューターが自分のがの強さをしっかり出してほしいんですけども
まずや楽しくやってほしい新メンバーのかもしれなくてその周りの人たちも楽しくやっ
てほしいから
協調性はあってほしいなと思っていま
楽しくないと続かないしどんどん気持ちも下がっていくと思うのでまずみんなと仲良く
できる人がいいなって思いますこのめっちゃどれどれで言いたいことですかねはいまあ
あのひとつ俺から言えることは楽しいです
間違いなく楽しいです俺立俺達まぁ使えなく楽しいんですけどもうほんと楽しんでる
だけじゃダメだし楽しみに来られる
だけでもダメだと思っていますなんなら畑をもっともっと伸ばせてほしい以上れの儲け
ははじめちゃんがいなくても成り立つチャンネルなんで
和美社長の羽田着俺が仕切るんだくらいの勢いで来られてもいいと思うんでもうお互い
の成長に繋がるぶつかり合いは俺は全然ありだと思うから側協調性とかではないと思い
ます私をよくするためでぶつかり合うことも大事なんでぜひと遅いやる気のある方を
募集しております
音が意図してキー件が短いんですよ8今日から11月の30日11月いっぱいまでの
募集になっておりますこれらの影響れながらここ人集めて面接っていうのもできないん
で人が少ないけど持参で面接すると思いますし共同買ったらオンラインになる予定も
ありますそこら辺はちょっとまた様子見ながら決めていこうと思いますはいという感じ
でですねもう肇社長の畑と言いつつはじめ市立青菅
でなく頑張れる人ぜひ募集しております
まずあの詳しい話は元肇社長の畑下のチャンネルでちゃんとしゃべってる明察
日本
たくさんのご応募をお待ちしておりますえっ
じゃんっ
[音楽]
eleanor